gonna go east to cincinnati and talk to
my man bill bill how are you
hey john how are you doing i'm doing
outstanding how about you
doing great great thanks for taking my
call um i want to say i'm really happy
you've been brought under the ramsey
team and i've really benefited from your
youtube videos and what you've done on
the radio so thank you so much for that
man
man thanks brother i appreciate you i'm
still figuring out how youtube works
but they tell me that if i keep plugging
away i'm going to learn how to
how to do it right so thank you so much
man so how can i help totally
well um i've been married for about
seven years and
we have a one and a half year old son so
my question is um
what are your insights on raising boys
and how
that would relate to the attack on
masculinity we are seeing these
days hmm so define number one let me
back up
congratulations on having a little baby
we waited i think
my wife and i eight years seven or eight
years to have our first kid so
i remember being where you are and you
are square in the middle of it and i
want to
promise you things get awesome get there
in a bit they get awesome
um so rewarding describe
the attacks what are you what are you
talking about
well you know how they just kind of in
the media and
this society is talking about
this toxic masculinity and so i want to
try and raise my son to just be
comfortable in his own skin
about being a man and obviously he's one
and a half so he's got a long way to go
but how can i as a father be encouraging
that
um you know who he is is okay
and being a man and being a godly
masculine man
is okay so let me ask you man how are
you
feeling attacked what are some things
you're hearing in the media what are
some things you're hearing
from people that you work with what are
some attacks you're feeling personally
that you're worried are going to rub off
on him
um give me some specifics i would say
like being the leader um
like not in a dominating way over your
house or your wife or anything like that
but
as we're called to be the leaders of our
houses um
you know there's this i guess we would
say attack on that
um there's kind of it's frowned upon
that men take charge and
um are looked to as the leaders and
um being confident like a man that's
confident and bold
is frowned upon um i guess those things
and
i guess i'm kind of navigating these
waters myself too um
as a you know within the past five years
it seems to be really a hot topic and so
i'm kind of trying to even
think about it and figure out like what
am i doing that
people might say is toxic and i don't
feel like i'm being toxic i feel like
i'm a nice person and
um i'm just trying to do the best i can
but um the blinds are getting so blurred
these days with
not even just this you know um so many
things
but um especially with just being a man
and masculinity it feels like they're
blurring those lines um what do you
think
so man i number one i want to applaud
you for the question
um and i want to applaud you for being
reflective and number two
i want to applaud you for being a dad
who's thinking ahead
um so many of us get so busy so
exhausted and we just try to get to the
next day to the next day the next day
that we
lose this intentionality um this
moment where we can just pause whether
we're driving or mowing the yard or
whatever
just to think man what kind of world is
my son inheriting
and what can i do right now to
participate there okay
so exactly here's a couple of things so
i live in the mental health world
and the apa the american psychological
association put out a paper
and maybe in a year or two three years
ago on toxic masculinity
and if i was to sum it up in my own
language here's how i would distill it
down
the things you mentioned about
leadership
confidence taking charge
domination i think the reason
those words have got a bad rap
is because those things have been used
those mantras those feelings those those
actions have been used to
abuse people to hold hostage people
and to really get people's way
you used a really really important word
that if you can
leave this phone call with that if the
listener can leave this phone call with
i will feel like i've done my job for
the next six months
you said um
not i don't want my son to feel like he
is over
and that is the main word when i think
of toxic masculinity
for whatever that means for whatever
different group right
i think of the difference between over
versus
with and so if i was to distill down
what i think toxic masculinity looks
like
is that we force our boys to prove their
worth
they do not understand at an early age
that they have inherent
value just because they're people just
because they're beings just because
they are worthy of being loved we set
them up in
conquests and in contests to when you do
these things
then you will prove your worthiness when
you do these things then
you will be worthy of fill in the blank
being a leader being a husband being a
man being a whatever
this idea that the bigger arms win
and often in nature that's the way it
works right the bigger lion
right like wins man and i think that
the the challenge there is we look
around at our communities we look around
at our country and if we look back the
last hundred years
the attack from folks who have not been
in power right
are looking at it and saying hey guys
y'all have always been president
hey guys y'all have always run the
finance system hey guys y'all have run
fill in the blank of institutions
churches
um schools whatever and every one of
those institutions is a mess right now
and so if i have a a job right if i've
got a business that i'm running
and the the business is a mess the buck
stops with the leader
and so as a guy i am balancing two
things right now
number one this idea of right what does
a head of a household look like what
does leadership look like
leadership does not look like head of
household does not look like
i get 51 of the vote i'm more powerful
i'm stronger i get to decide what i'm
training my son who's 10 now
is leadership means you get underneath
everything and hold it up leadership
means you go
last leadership means if there is a
fight to be had you go
first you are the first one to be on the
front of the line
and when people are eating or people are
showering or people
are in need you go last and so this idea
of
not the leaders eat the nicest the
leaders eat what's
left and so it's this idea of submission
and that is a reframing of masculinity
for me
another thing is this idea of being with
i want my son to know
that when he is married when he's got
kids
when he is a community leader when he is
a boss when he is a coworker
his job is not to look for people to
have dominion over
it's to look to people to have
relationships with
and the most effective way um we see it
here at ramsey solutions i work for dave
ramsey here
um business moves at the speed of trust
and trust is is is fostered around a
table where people eat together they
commune together they hang out together
it's when people are with now somebody
who's in charge
um the boss if you will the buck stops
there right somebody's got to make a
call and that can be man
and woman i report to amy who reports to
jeremy who reports to suzanne who
reports to dave right so i've got
two women i think i've almost always had
women leaders throughout my career
the buck stops with them right um so
whoever's the boss boss but
that's less about gender and more about
position um so when it comes
all the way back to it i'm talking a lot
to just to say this i want
my son to know he's got value
that he is allowed to feel feelings that
he is allowed to
love deeply that he's allowed to use
words and ask
for hey dad can i have a hug i want him
to know that he is
valuable just because he exists
and i want him to teach i want to teach
him to use his strength use his he is
a monster dude my son i don't i think my
wife is injecting him with roids on the
weekends dude he's huge
i want him to um use his
physical position he's a big kid i want
him to use that
wisely and boldly and strongly
and also not to empower and i mean not
to
overpower and crush people but to serve
people right
so that's my that's my spiel on
masculinity
um how does that ring true in your heart
when you hear it
that's great i mean definitely a lot of
good points to
reflect on um i really liked especially
what you said in the beginning about we
sometimes put
the earning mark on
our boys that if you do x y and z or we
expect you to do
whatever good at football or win the
sports game or something like that and
then you're
you're doing your job then um tearing
down that wall
and just loving them for who they are
and not getting caught into that trap um
that's a great insight i think and
here's the other thing that you're just
gonna have to hold close to your heart
and that is this
i say this often and it's just a good
saying to put in your back pocket
and it's not by my hand but in my lap
you are a guy raising a young son
in a cultural mess we owe too much money
we're having to deal with racial racial
reconciliation
that we have swept under the rug and not
dealt with for years and years and years
and years and years
we are dealing with international
challenges we are dealing with weather
challenges i got family in houston right
now waiting for the second hurricane in
like a week to come through
um we've got fires raging in california
and colorado i mean things are a mess
and it's just been dropped in your lap
in this little snapshot in history
and so people are going to talk bad
about you just because you're you
and you get to decide am i going to
carry that baggage or i'm going to
set it down i'm going to work really
hard to be a good guy in my home
to be a good man in my community in my
neighborhood to listen
when i feel like someone's hurting my
feelings i want to lean in and say what
can i learn from this and the rest of
them is going to put that nonsense down
and raise a son who knows how to love
who knows how to speak up for himself
and who knows how to serve and protect
his community
and service comes from underneath and
behind man and if you get on that track
if you can teach him to hear what he
needs to hear and to
not carry other nonsense bricks down
everyone's going to be throwing rocks at
you man
regardless of what it is you do they're
going to throw rocks at
you for who you are for what you want to
be for the sun you want that's just
going to be life man
it's happened throughout history and it
will always happen
i want to know where i my values are
grounded
i want my son to know he's loved i want
my daughter to know she's loved want my
wife to
to know she's loved and i want them to
see it and feel it in me not just words
they got to hear that too but
see it and feel it and brother bill the
fact again i want to reiterate this the
fact that you are already thinking this
through
as a dad of a one and a half year old
man blessings to you brother you are way
way way ahead of the curve